Tom Holland hey everyone
yes my man whoa ladies and gentlemen the
director of spider-man homecoming John
Watts hey John what we have we've just
started early we've just started filming
this movie in Atlanta and it's amazing
to bring this character portrayed by
this guy into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it wouldn't be possible and
wouldn't have been possible without our
producing partner on this movie Amy
Pascal who's out there somewhere but she
is the reason that all of this happened
because she knew what was putting
everything else aside here's what's best
for the character here's what's best for
Spidey
who everybody loves spider-man yeah of
course I mean it was it was such I wrote
was such huge news in our world when you
guys were getting him back and to find
out that he's going to be in Civil War
and everyone's like oh how is this gonna
and then the second you came on screen
is like that's the guy he's the guy so I
think how how is this portrayal of
spider-man different than what we've
seen and how are you guys tackling it
well first of all this it's a pretty
cool universe to be a partner right I
mean jeez um it's a high school movie
it's a straight-up high school movie
it's about a 15 year old kid it's I
always describe it as this is the ground
level of the Marvel Universe
you know we know what it's like to be a
billionaire playboy inventor and we know
what it's like to be a alien God from
another dimension we're gonna learn what
it's like to go to the astral plane and
we're also gonna learn what it's like
you know to have just finished going
through puberty and be in tenth grade
thank you and I'll be in Queens
did you bring some stuff today that you
could show everyone
uh well would you just start shooting
which actually be shooting right now
probably we shot some of the height we
shot some the high school stuff um so we
can show that all right we should yeah
good [ __ ] I want to say we right
they literally flew here today they're
flying out tonight we've been shooting
for ten days
but here's what we've been shooting it
you ever seen anything yet no we got
some we got some of oil here they're
high school students here oh if you want
to bring them out
Laura Tony zendaya Jacob come on out
whoa
well guys so this is this is game like a
it's just like a John Hughes II kind of
a spin is that does that accurate yeah
absolutely I mean it's just it's man
wouldn't you really want to tell
everyone that you were spider-man yeah
if you if you had to keep that secret in
high school man driving crazy yeah we
really tried to just capture sort of the
spirit of those movies and bring it into
this crazy universe yeah um
how is it for how has it been for you
guys so far 10 days into this really I
mean is it sunk in what's going on right
now everything like this moment feels
really fake like none of this is real
but uh it's real Israel except the love
except the love is amazing well thank
you guys so much for being here I know
you guys literally an ending work yeah
you're literally leaving right after
this to go back and continue shooting
and then hopefully we'll see some more
stuff some rolls out but it look amazing
and a gank you ever once you guys and
Tom Hollands thank you guys thank you
Scott Derrickson liner man I'm coming
Tom home
you